hello everyone i'm abhijit and i'll be
talking to you all about our paper time
space lower bounds for simulating proof
systems with quantum and randomized
verifiers
and this is joint work with ryan
williams at mit
uh so for starters this is a pretty long
title so let's break it up break it down
a bit
uh so what are time special amounts well
let x be either a specific problem or
a set of problems so a complexity class
excuse me our goal is to show that x
cannot be solved by algorithms that are
simultaneously fast
and use a limited amount of memory so
there could be a fast algorithm or there
could be a small space algorithm but we
want to show that
there's no algorithm that's both at once
uh and
when x is a complexity class by the way
we just mean that there is a problem in
x that does not have such algorithms
uh and it'll be helpful in order to
state our results to define the
following complexity class so let uh
ts to the c be the class corresponding
to
uh random axis machines that are
simultaneously end to the little of one
space
and o of n to the c time
uh and with this in mind we can give our
first example of a time space lower
bound
which is due to orion balloons in 2007
and it's that sat the satisfiability
problem
is not contained in ts and to the c if c
is less than 1.801 so what is this
saying this
is saying that there is no random access
machine
which runs in say log n space and end to
the 1.8 time
that solves satisfiability on length and
inputs
and the reason i wanted to bring this
theorem up
now is because all our results are going
to be more or less of this form
they're going to be able to form a
problem in x
where x is a some capacity class cannot
be solved by a y
machine y is going to specify the
computational model
that uses small space and o of n to c
time
if c is smaller than z z is going to be
some constant like 1.801
cool the other part of the title was
proof systems with quantum and
randomized verifiers so
what are those well they're complexity
classes
uh you're all probably familiar with np
which is those languages whose yes
instances have classical proofs which
can be verified in
polynomial time by a deterministic
verifier and by classical proof heroes
mean like
a bit string so we have approver
and the previous sentence proof to the
deterministic verifier and the verifier
processes the input and the proof
together and returns uh zero or one
and so you should think of this in our
language as a
proof system with a deterministic
verifier so now what might a proof
system with a randomized verifier be
well it means that we allow the verifier
to use randomness
uh and this gives us the complexity
class m a or merlin arthur
we can go one step further and allow the
verifier to be a quantum algorithm
in which case we get qcma qcma is
quantum classical merlin arthur
note here that the proof itself is still
a class it's still classical there's no
quantum element to the proof but the
verification procedure is quantum
and qcma is an example of a proof system
with a quantum verifier
and it's actually the complexity class
we're going to focus on in this talk
some of you might have heard of qma
which is similar to qsma but
the proofs are also allowed to be
quantum we're not really going to talk
about qma in this talk
but i just wanted to mention it to make
the distinction clear
so with all this in mind we can now
state our results
uh actually one more thing i should say
before i see the results
is that qram is going to stand for a
quantum random access machine and if you
aren't familiar with quantum random axis
then
think of it analogous to classical
random axes there is some
uh there is some standard model of
quantum computation in our case
we're gonna take the uniform uh quantum
circuit model
and quantum anamaxis is essentially a
way to
uh it essentially gives the machine
additional power to access
uh certain parts of the data workspace
input etc
uh oh and we can if you want more
details on this you can check out our
paper but our
theorems are pretty robust to most
standard notions of qrm
cool so theorem one is that linear tying
qcma on a qram
or qcma time n as we'll call it
henceforth
is not in ts and to the c for c less
than
point three six six so what is linear
time qcma and a qram mean well
uh it means that the verifier is a
a quantum atom axis machine and it runs
in linear
time linear in the length of the input
so it receives like
uh it uh it has an input and it receives
some uh
something from the uh it just sees a
classical it just is a proof string
and then it runs some linear time
verification process on a qram and
uses that to decide whether or not
whether to accept it to reject
and the you should compare this to the
classical analog of this theorem which
is
due to williams from o7 and it's that
non-deterministic linear time on a ram
or end time event is not in ts and to
the c for c
less than 1.801 so the
sort of how you should think about these
two in relation to each other is that
n10 n is contained in qcma time n and so
essentially we're saying okay if we make
the
complexity class in question bigger from
like end time and qcma time in
or bigger probably
uh then uh
if if we make the complexity class in
question bigger we can prove a stronger
lower bound because we're able to
increase the lower bound exponent from
one point eight zero one to two point
three six six
cool so uh and both fans are obtained by
the method of quantify trading proofs
and we're going to talk a lot about
quantifier trading proofs
uh during this talk uh but briefly
before i get to
the sketch of theorem before i get to
like the methods and techniques used to
prove theorem one
i just want to briefly mention the other
two theorems in the paper we're not
going to
talk very much about those but i just
wanted to state them just so they're in
your minds
theorem two is that there exists a
problem in
linear time m a on a ram uh
which is not decidable by bonded air
probabilistic grams using o of log n
space and o of n to the c
time for c less than 1.465 so there's a
couple of things to unpack here
first off linear time m a on a ram this
is defined in the same way as linear
time qcma on a qrm is
the verifier is a random access machine
and it runs in
it's a random access machine that's
allowed to use randomness hence merlin
arthur
and it runs in linear time but the other
thing is that unlike before where our
we the we're sort of unlike before where
we're talking about ts and to the c
here where here the rams in question are
probabilistic because it's not decided
by bounded error probabilistic rams and
so the flavor of the proof is a little
bit different
but the essential ideas are pretty
similar
and this is an improvement over a result
of deal from o7
who proved uh theorem two for c less
than one point four one four
square root two theorem three is that if
we replace
linear time m a on a ram with linear
time qcma on a qram
we can increase the lore of an exponent
to uh just under 1.5
cool i'm not going to talk about theorem
2 and theorem theorem 3 for the rest of
the talk but
uh you're welcome to check out the paper
for details on this
uh so here's the roadmap for the rest of
the talk we're first going to talk about
how we can get time-space lower bounce
from quantifier trading proofs
and in particular we're going to talk
about speed up and slow down rules which
are the
key components of a quantifier trading
proof
we're then going to talk about how we
can get quantified trading proofs with
generic slowdown rules or in particular
how we can get
sort of better quantify trading proofs
with generic slowdown rules and
generation the generic solar unreal
methodology is something we introduced
in this work
uh and third we're gonna talk about how
we can get generic solid and rules in
the quantum setting from
using grover's algorithm and sort of the
idea is uh
grower's algorithm gives us a generic
solid rule generic slowdown rules give
us better quantifier trading proofs
and better quantifier trading proofs
mean better lower bounds and that's
how this entire thing is going to fit
together
and uh just henceforth the rest of this
talk i'm going to play fast and loose
with small terms meaning constants and
subpolynomial factors i'm just going to
hand wave away and if you want those
details you should check out our paper
let's start off by talking about
quantified trading crews uh this is
mostly going to be a review of
uh existing work so like none for the
most part this isn't going to be
anything that we
did in this work but it's worth uh
giving that background now
so the key components of quantified
tuning proofs are alternating complexity
classes
uh which are or you should think of
these as fine grained versions of sigma
kp or pi kp for some
positive case so like and the sigma kp
and pi kp are the levels of the
polynomial hierarchy
and what do you mean when you say fine
grained well an example is something
like this
exists n squared for all n to the 0.3
t s n to the fifth so this is something
in sigma 2 p
and but we want a little bit more we
want to be precise about how exactly
this works
and so let's give an example of a
machine in
the class exists n squared for all n to
the zero point three t s end
to the fifth so uh on an n bit input
there's gonna be three stages of
computation
the first is that we're going to guess a
length and squared string and then feed
the input and
our guest and squared string into an
intermediate small space machine
the output of the intermediate machine
is then going to go to another
intermediate machine along with the
guess from the second quantifier
and the second point on the output of
the second quantifier has to be of
length
and to the 0.3 so like the exponents are
telling us how large the guesses are
essentially
and then the output of the second
interior machine goes to
an end to the fifth time small space
machine uh
hence tsn to the fifth and uh this is
going to return zero or one
and as a standard for uh class in the
polynomial hierarchy
we accept if and only if there exists a
guess from the first quantifier
such as for all guesses from the second
quantifier the verifier accepts
uh there i am being hand wavy here there
is important details with like how
exactly the intermediate space machines
work
that do matter and that i'm glossing
over for the purposes of this talk
uh but you should if you're curious
about this you should definitely check
out the paper since we
elaborate on this a lot in the
preliminary section
uh i think the one thing that's worth
stating though is that like
just for the purpose of this talk you
can pretend that the runtime of the
intermediate space machine
is smaller than the runtime of the last
machine
so like basically the intermediate
machines are fast enough they're not
really going to affect their own time
you shouldn't really worry about them
i guess also one other thing i should
say is that i'm going to be pretty
sloppy with
like big o notation henceforth so like i
might say like
if i say n squared i might actually know
n squared or if the notation says n to
the fifth it might actually mean over n
to the fifth
uh this uh you shouldn't this shouldn't
be too important in order to follow the
basic logic
uh but yeah just to keep our uh words
clear
i'm gonna call the the existential
quantifier and the subsequent
intermediate machine the existential
part
uh the universal quantifier and the
subsequent engineering machine the
universal part
and the uh last machine the verifier
uh oh and in case you're curious this
photo is one of sauron kierkegaard a
famous existentialist philosopher
cool so with this in mind we can say a
little bit more about quantify trading
proofs
so as mentioned uh they're built up from
alternating complexity classes which are
fine-grained versions of sigma kp or pi
kp
and we gave uh an example of a machine
in
such an alternating complexity class and
now a quantifier trading proof is just a
conditional sequence of inclusions of
alternating complexity classes
uh and how do we show inclusions well
there's two ways uh the speed up rule
and the slow down rule
let's start with the speed up rule the
speed up row adds two quantifiers to an
alternating complexity class and reduces
the runtime of the verifier
and for example we can use the speed up
rule to show that tsn squared is
contained in
exists n for all log n ts n
and this is just saying that every
language that's decidable by a machine
in tsn squared
is also decidable by some machine in
exists n for all log n psn
the idea is that we can break the
computation of any psn squared machine
into n pieces each of its will be n
steps long
and verify each piece separately so if
say this is the computational tableau of
a tsn squared machine note by the way
that it's entered a little over one
space because
ts is a complexity class of uh
corresponding to small space machines
so now on an n-bit input terminal
language in tsn squared
uh so in accepting an accepted input
the existential part guesses n plus one
configurations
each of which has size and a little of
one
and the configuration discusses will be
the initial configuration
n minus one intermediate configurations
and the accepting configuration
so these are the guesses of the
existential part then the universal part
picks a pair of adjacent guest
configurations and discards the other
states
and note that this only takes roughly
log n bits because there's
n plus one configurations and you just
want to just in paris
so it'll be something like this and then
the verifier runs for n steps starting
at the first configuration it receives
and accepts if it reaches the second and
the idea is that
since the existential part can guess the
actual intermediate configurations of
the original tsn squared machine
will accept if the input was in the
language and you can work out what
happens if the input is not in language
two important things to keep note of
here are that first
that the speed up roll produces small
quantifiers as in over log n bits
the second is that the universal part in
uh machine on the right hand side of the
inclusion
is essentially acting as a search for a
bad intermediate configuration
and this is going to be important later
so a slow down rule removes a quantifier
from an alternating complexity class at
the cost of increasing the rent at the
verifiers likely
and slow down rolls are generally going
to be conditional on some assumptions so
for example
assume that n time of n
non-deterministic linear time on a ram
is containing ts and to the c for some c
greater than one
then exists n for all n t s n is
contained in
exists n t s and the c and to see why
this is the case
uh notice that on the left hand side of
the inclusions
the universal parking to verify together
so that's for all and tsn
this uh together is something from cohen
time man
and uh well note that the assumption n
time n and t assigned to the c
also implies that cohen time n is
contained in tsn to the c because
ts and to the c is closed during the
complementation
and so then the inclusion falls uh cool
so
with this in mind we can now uh fully
describe upon graduating groups
so as mentioned all alternating
complexity classes are fine-grained
versions of levels of the polynomial
hierarchy and we give an example of
machine in an alternating complexity
class
and quantify trading proofs are
conditional sequences of inclusions of
alternating complexity classes
and we have two ways of showing such
inclusions speed up rules which add
quantifiers and reduce the runtime and
we give an example as such
and a slowdown rule which conditionally
removes quantifiers and increases the
runtime
and we give an example of a slowdown
rule as well
the idea is that given stronger
assumptions in the slowdown rule we can
prove stronger inclusions
and ultimately we can even prove
impossible inclusions we can prove
inclusions that violate some sort of a
time hierarchy theorem
and this if we're able to do so this
means that the assumption we use must
have been false
and in particular the contradiction
we're going to go for is uh
that ts and to the d is containing tsn
to the d prime for d prime less than d
this isn't on its own a contradiction
because we don't have a ts hierarchy
but it turns out that this uh implies a
contradiction in our sentence
so here's an example of a time space
excuse me i have a quantified trading
proof
uh dating back to lipton vigolos from 99
uh so we'll start by assuming that end
time of n is contained in ts and to the
c for some c greater than one
uh let's start with tsn squared so uh
basically tsn squared is going to be the
first
alternating complexity class in our
chain of inclusions of alternating
complexity classes
so you can visualize the computation as
follows you have an n-bit input
it goes into an n-squared times small
space machine would stand up at 0 1.
we can start by applying the speed up
rule
which shows that t s n squared is
contained in exists n for all log n
t s n we mentioned how this might be
proved earlier
and uh this is now what the right-hand
side looks like we have an n-bit input
the existential part the universal part
the verifier
and the output by the definition of coen
time n
this uh the universal part and the
verified together are
just a coin time and machine and so
by assumption as mentioned we can
replace this with ts and to the c
this is uh this can be thought of as the
application of this load on rule
now uh we can this in turn is now an
end time intimacy why is that well we
can uh squash the
intermediate machine and the antic time
machine into a single and to the c time
machine
again we're assuming that the
intermediate machine is not contributing
too much to the runtime this
ends up being true and so
after the squashing this is what the
computation looks like and now it's
clear that
we have an exists n part which is
the proof essentially and the
verification is the end of the c time so
overall this is an
end time of n to the c
by assumption if we uh
uh it might we can use a slowdown rule
which can be thought of like assumption
plus
a padding step so this is an tsn to this
c
squared uh because if n time n is nts n
to the c then n time n to the c is in ts
and to the c squared and
now we have a contradiction if c squared
is less than 2
and that statement holds regardless of
whether you read the the exclamation
point as a factorial or as punctuation
so now we see that enzyme n is not in ts
and to the c
for c less than the square root of two
because if c less than square root of
two then c squared is smaller than two
this is a nice how do we do better
well this was achieved by ryan williams
this was shooting uh several works
building up to
uh uh ryan williams's time space flower
bound for anti-men
uh from o7 which is that end time of n
is not contained in ts and to the c
for c less than one point eight zero one
and
the proof is somewhat similar uh
with one major major difference uh
assume that n time of n
is contained in ts n to the c for some c
uh this gives us a slowdown rule and
now we may apply the speed up rule and
this slow down rule in a carefully
chosen order
this is the really important part uh
essentially
the the the real the content of quantum
factory proofs is coming up with
the right order and the right set of
parameters in order to prove the
strongest inclusions possible
and i won't go into how one comes up
with these things but
you should check out this paper the uh
the paper of williamson seven if you are
curious about how these were initially
but ultimately we can show that tsn to
the d is contained in tsn to the d
prime for d prime less than d if c is
smaller than 1.801
so just by because
enzyme n is contained in qcmation we
automatically have that qcma time n
is not contained in tsn to the 1.8
because
anti-man is not containing ts and 1.8 so
qcma time definitely shouldn't be
so let's consider c greater than 1.8 and
we want to show that
even this cannot work for at least some
c that are larger than 1.8
uh so yeah now we're now we're getting
to the new contribution of this paper
which is getting better bounds for
linear time qcma
uh so we're going to let's introduce the
notion of a generic slowdown rule
a genetic squadron rule is a slowdown
rule so again slowdown rules are
quantifier
are conditional quantifier removing
rules basically
uh and the generic flood angle is a
slowdown rule associated with some
parameter
between zero and one it's allowed to be
one it's not allowed to be zero
and conditionally shows inclusions of
the form uh
it might show something like existing
for all log for excuse me
exists and for exists n
squared for all n t s n to the fifth is
contained in
exists and squared ts and to the five
alpha c
uh and just to be clear the regular
slowdown rule is generic with alpha
equals one so the slowdown rule we've
been discussing so far
uh before this slide it would have shown
it would have shown
existence squared for all n t s n to the
fifth is contained in existence squared
ts enter the 5c this is uh the same sort
of padding argument that we used a few
slides ago
but the key idea is that if we can if we
can prove a generic slot unroll with
an alpha that's less than one then we
get a stronger inclusion
and uh stronger inclusions mean stronger
lower bounds and contradictions for
larger values of c
so that's basically how we're going to
proceed we're going to try to prove a
generic slope we're going to try to show
that
uh some assumptions that we're able to
make
prove uh imply generic slowdown rules
for an alpha that's smaller than one
so what exactly does this give us first
uh well we can do some algebra and
uh we get the following theorem let x be
complexity class
and here's the theorem if the assumption
x can t
is contained in ts and to the c implies
the generic slowdown rule with parameter
alpha
then x is not contained in ts and to the
c whenever x is smaller than the largest
root of some polynomial that depends on
alpha
so
here's an example assume that enzyme n
is contained in ts and to the c this
implies a generic slowdown rule with
alpha equals one
uh it turns out to rather um
so plugging alpha equals one into this
theorem
we get the polynomial x cubed minus x
squared minus two x plus one
the largest root of this polynomial is
uh 2 cosine pi over 7 which is roughly
1.881 and this is actually
an alternate proof of the uh earlier
result that we mentioned
which is that and time of n is not
contained in ts and the 1.801
so we already see how this uh gives us
an existing theorem
now how do we use it to get something
for how do you use it to get something
new
well we want to apply the theorem when x
is qcma time
n which again is linear time qcma on a
qram
and we and we're going to do this is
that we're going to hope that we can get
a generic slowdown roll with a smaller
value of alpha
from the stronger assumption uh because
the assumption qcna time n is containing
tsn to the c
for a given c is stronger than the
assumption and time n is contained in
the tsn to the c
and we're hoping that the stronger
assumption means a smaller alpha and
hence a stronger
lower bond at the end
cool so uh now we're on to the next step
which is how do we prove genetic
slowdown rules
in the quantum setting uh spoiler alert
it's going to be with purpose locating
uh so think back to when we were
discussing the speed up role and we
mentioned
uh these two important points uh the
first was that the speeder full produces
small quantifiers and by small i mean
like log n
things like log n as opposed to things
like
n squared or n and the second is that
the universal part
searches for is essentially acting as a
search for a bad
intermediate state it's essentially the
because the essential part is guessing
intermediate states
and then the universal part is checking
to see if there's a
adjacent pair of bad intermediate states
which uh
well which which is inconsistent where
like i can't run computation from one
state and reach the other
in the specified amount of time so
we're going to essentially use uh a
quantum computer to
efficiently remove small quantifiers and
well in this case the small quantifier
is acting as a search so
uh the idea is that we can use grover
search
so in case you're not familiar with
grubber's algorithm here's a
quick overview uh gerber's algorithm is
designed to solve the following problem
given f from zero one zero one to the m
to zero one
find x such that f of x equals one so
essentially we're
inverting f at the output one
a deterministic machine may need truly m
evaluations
uh of f and r to solve this problem
because it might just need it it just
needs to try every single input and hope
that it hits one sooner rather than
later
a quantum computer can do better a
quantum computer can actually solve this
theorem
using o of 2 to the m over 2 evaluations
of f so this is
like roughly a square root square root
improvement over the deterministic
machine
and now let's try applying german's
algorithm to exists and
for all log and tsn so
as mentioned a machine from this
complexity class takes an embed input
there's an existential part a universal
part a verifier and the output
so let's start by uh
sort of combining uh the second
intermediate machine and the verifier
and then let's fix the output from the
the extension part
so now what we're left with is the green
box which is a function of
the the guess of the universal
quantifier so it takes the guess from
the universal quantifier
along with the fixed output of this
existential part and
returns zero one
we're going to apply grover's algorithm
to the green box
so just to just to
make it clear like the reason this makes
sense in our the reason we want to do
this is because
the the universal quantifier is
basically saying
uh or rather the the way that the way
this uh machine is being used that we're
asking
does there is it true that for all
log n bit strings the output
of the the output of the green box is
one
uh because if so then we're happy and if
not then if so then we
accept essentially if not we reject so
essentially what we're doing is a search
so we just want to search over
all the possible inputs and see if there
is an input
that uh all the possible inputs has and
all the possible guesses from the
universal quantifier
and see is there a guess that gives us
zero
well we can invert the green box with
root and evaluations of the green box
because
uh a 2 to the log n over 2 is root n
each iteration of the green box takes o
event time again we're assuming the
intermediate space machine
doesn't really matter asymptotically so
that means that we can replace the
universal part in the verifiers like
this and
everything that's on the screen right
now rather everything every everything
the diagram
can be replaced with an o of n to the
three halves times quantum machine
so
now putting back the existential part we
see that
we have an input the existential part we
have the input the extensor part and the
end to the 3x time quantity machine
this machine is in qcma time n to the
three halves
by padding really by definition
uh and if we assume that qcma time n is
contained in ts and to the c for some c
then uh now by padding uh we can replace
the quantifier and the quantum verifier
with uh ts n to the 3c over 2 because
uh qcma time into three halves and then
you multiplied by c but because
uh qcma time n is contained in ts
antenna c so
this is what we're left with in the end
an n bit input goes into a
uh deterministic into the three three c
over two time small space machine
but uh remember that earlier when we did
the same thing with the
glass argument we got n n to the c
squared so like
essentially we've done better than what
we sort of got
with the simple with the original
argument when c is greater than one
point eight
or really once once he's greater than
one play this is an improvement and
this is sort of the key idea like by
using grover's algorithm
rather than by just using the slowdown
rule
uh we're able to show stronger
inclusions than we are otherwise
so now we can just do some technical
stuff
and ultimately obtain the phone
uh lemma the assumption qcma time n in
ts and to the c
yields a generic slowdown rule with
parameter alpha equals two thirds
uh just to recap how this sort of
happened we saw in the example that
we're able to do better than the lipton
big glass bound
uh by using grover's algorithm to remove
a quantifier
rather than just using the the slowdown
rule via assumption
and it turns out that when one works
this out you can
show that it's actually a generic slot
it yields a generous generic slowdown
rule of parameter alpha equals
two-thirds
uh we earlier showed that if the
assumption x and tsn to the c implies a
generic slowdown rule with some
parameter alpha then
x is not in ts n to the c if c is
smaller than the largest root of
some polynomial dependent on alpha so
now now that we have a value of alpha
and a general slowdown rule we can plug
alpha equals two thirds into the theorem
to get
ki same a time n is not contained in ts
and to the c
for c less than three plus square root
of three over two which is roughly two
point three six six
and there we have it uh this is theorem
one as promised
so now let me just briefly uh close by
talking about some future work
uh one thing that we would be really
nice is that we'd like to get
a lower bound on a specific problem like
we have a lower bound on qcma timing so
that means
there's some problem in key cma time and
that can't be solved by small space fast
algorithms
but we want to we like ideally a lower
bound on a specific problem
like we'd be like to ideally be able to
say like oh this problem this is a hard
one here
and a candidate problem is the k local
hamiltonians problem since it's a qma
complete so it's definitely
hard for qcma uh and
recalled this theorem from earlier we
showed we didn't show this but we
mentioned that
sat cannot be solved by ram that uses
small space and o
n to the c times simultaneously if c is
less than 1.801
the idea of this proof uh is that we can
pass through the end time of n lower
bound
which we also mentioned earlier to the
sat lower bound
and by this like earlier we showed that
end time of n
is not contained in ts n to the c for c
u less than one point eight zero one
and the idea is that it turns out we can
pass from that lower bound on a
complexity plus to the specific
lower bound on stop and we sort of hope
to do the same for our loraban and qcma
timeman
and how does the how does the how does
it work in the classical case well
uh first uh one shows that
non-deterministic linear time on a ram
is not contained in ts
and to the c for c less than one point
eight zero one this is end time and is
not contained in tsn to the c
or c less than one point eight oh one uh
there's the theorem of gurus and salah
from 89 that shows that
non-deterministic linear time on a ram
is quasi-linearly so up to poly logs
equivalent to linear time
np on a multi-tape turing machine so
we've gone from rams to multi-tape
turing machines
that's what happened here uh that should
this should say non-deterministic linear
time on a ram is quasi-linearly
equivalent to non-deterministic linear
time on a multi-tape turing machine
and it's a theorem of cook from 88 that
sac the satisfiability problem is
complete for a non-deterministic linear
time on a multi-tape turing machine
under quasi-linear size quasi-linear
time small space reductions
so putting all these together gives us
uh lets us pass from
uh lower bond on end time of n
non-deterministic linear time around
to sat because essentially it says okay
well not a lower bound and
non-international stick linear time of
ram is equivalent to a lower bound
up to polylog is equal into a lower
bound on uh
non-deterministic linear time on a
multi-tape turning machine and
uh sat is complete for non-international
anytime on a multi-tier machine so
chaining these together we get that
sat also cannot be in tsn to the c for c
smaller than
1.801 so now
how do we lift this to our setting
well the theorem that we proved in this
talk is that the linear time key same
and a qram is not contained in ts and to
the c
for c less than 2.366 uh
it's all we also know that uh two local
hamiltonians is hard for
linear time qcma in the uniform circuit
model under quasi-linear size
quasi-linear times small space
reductions
uh but what's missing is this middle
link
we'd like to show ideally that linear
time key semianna qram is quasi-linearly
equivalent to linear time key similar in
the uniform circuit model and if we can
show this then
we uh well then we have then we have a
lower bound on two local hamiltonians
which would be nice but that's
essentially the
the obstruction right now uh cool
uh that's all i really wanted to talk
about today so uh thank you for your
time and
uh i hope you all have a wonderful day
thank you